encountering bosses in Metroid games is
like opening a horrifying box of
chocolates you never quite know what
you're going to get from dangerous
ancient Machinery to mutated carnivorous
plants to explosively failed experiments
and so much more it's always so
interesting to brush up on Metroid lore
even if you haven't played the games for
the first of many boss lore videos
covering the Metroid franchise on the
channel I chose to cover Metroid Prime
as it is my favorite Metroid title and
you know maybe talking about it will
wound Nintendo into making Metroid Prime
4 a thing because at this point I'm
beginning to think we all just
hallucinated the teaser trailer into
existence over 6 years ago anyway the
last thing I'll mention is the criteria
I used to consider an enemy a boss for
the purposes of this video which would
be rather simple if it's not an obvious
boss you know that has its own theme and
health bar and whatnot then I consider a
powerful enemy that unlocks upgrades for
Samus upon its defeat to be a boss make
sense cool so without further Ado sit
back relax and enjoy this deep dive into
the stories and lore behind each of the
bosses of Metroid Prime oh yeah yeah and
spoiler alert obviously in order to more
efficiently cover the lore of these
bosses we're going to talk about them in
groups that is to say we're going to
first group the bosses together based on
certain similarities and knock them out
Group by group the first group we're
going to cover would be the easiest
bosses that are native species to the
planet Talon 4 which is the planet the
game takes place on this would include
the giant armored Beetle known as the
plated Beetle the apex predator of the
Frozen fendron drifts known as the shof
and the mutated flow known as flagra
although there's something unique about
that last one which we will get to later
on the plated beetle is by far the
easiest boss to understand not only in
this game but probably in the entirety
of Metroid lore it's just a big
predatory beetle with kitan so dense and
strong that it acts as armor that
renders it literally invulnerable to any
attacks from the front hence the name
plated Beetle the first of these large
bugs that Samus encounters guards the
morphball its design is very reminiscent
of the rhinoceros beetle species from
this other universe that I like to call
real life it really is just a big Beetle
though no mutations or any other
influences to be found and we can even
see the smaller younger Beetle variants
throughout the planet as well many of
which are encountered by Samus
throughout her time on the planet the
sheo despite being a completely
different kind of animal shares a very
similar explanation it's a large
predatory species that's native to the
blisteringly cold biome on Talon 4 known
as fendron drifts and also similarly to
the plated Beetle we can see baby she
gos alongside the significantly larger
and significantly angrier adult she goth
the first of which is the biggest and
scariest of them all and acts as the
boss guarding the wave beam upgrade for
samus's power suit interestingly the
jagged crystal-like growths on the sho's
back have a unique property that
attracts energy such as samus's beam
weapons in fact any beam that Samus
Fires at the sheoth will instead home to
these invulnerable crystals and deal no
damage to the sheoth with the exception
of the plasma beam which does not really
care about crystals the last boss in
this section as mentioned previously is
the living killer plant known as FL but
unlike the previous two bosses flagra
isn't natural it's a heavily mutated UV
ray loving plant that has grown well
beyond the limits of your average
sunflower but I know what you're
thinking what caused it to mutate and
what a lovely question that is so allow
me to briefly introduce and explain what
caused this mutation as well as all of
the other bosses on this list and all of
the events of the entire Metroid Prime
series of games including the creation
of the titular boss known as the Metroid
Prime a little planetary Threat Level
substance known as fison fison in a
nutshell is a highly radioactive
substance that hailes from a sensient
planet far across the galaxies known as
Faze or Faz if you want to get fancy
with it I'll go into more detail
regarding the details behind its true
purpose in my eventual video covering
the bosses of Metroid Prime 3 since that
is the game that revealed lots of the
secrets of fison to us hm it's almost
like you should be subscribed if you
want to be here when that video drops
but anyway for the purposes of this
video just know for the time being that
Fon was spread throughout the Universe
from from F by way of giant living
Wormhole warping meteorites known as the
leviathans that would Target and crash
into other planets such as Talon 4 and
infect that planet with the deadly goop
assumedly to turn the other planets into
other phases the choso of Talon 4 who
were living on the planet when it was
struck by its Leviathan bore witness to
the rampant spread and Corruption of
life itself by fison and thus even refer
to the substance as the great poison in
their prophecies but back to flagra even
though it's pretty pretty easily
understood that it's now a giant Fason
mutated nightmare plant there's still
much to be deduced regarding its
original purpose its location being
within the sun Chamber Of The choso
Ruins implies a lot especially when you
also notice that there's plenty of water
located directly underneath the plant
AKA surrounding its roots and there are
four giant solar panels that reflect the
sun's beams built into the room Each of
which can be tilted to control the
amount of sun the plant receives it's
very likely due to these features which
were built by the choso that this
chamber was always meant to house plant
life and perhaps this plant was quite
literally just a sunflower of some kind
that the choso had planted here and were
nurturing within the sun chamber
possibly to study which they like to do
or maybe just because it was pretty
after fison was introduced to the planet
and spread through its Earth the flagra
was eventually tainted and caused to
mutate wildly poisoning the water inside
the Sun chamber and throughout the choso
ruins it's also ironic to note that its
massive mutated size is the very thing
that causes it to be defeated by Samos
due to its hugeness it requires constant
direct concentrated sunlight in order to
remain mobile whenever Samus tilts the
solar panels away from The Nightmare
plant it literally Falls helplessly to
the ground the fagra drops the various
suit when defeated with the mostly
natural Talon four bosses out of the way
let us now move on to the next category
the boss is created by the choso of
which there are only two non-organic
bosses the first boss is a mechanical
construct known as The Hive Mecca also
located Within the choso Ruins this
machine was specifically designed by the
Cho to serve as a home for organic units
in this case the dangerous Ram War wasps
which it releases periodically in order
to attack its enemy natively though it
has no way to attack it's also
completely invulnerable to any attack
from any weapon except for the power
beamman missiles which is a detail that
is interesting enough to assume it was
meant to be intentional it's never
explicitly stated as to why it was
created but since it clearly conceals
the missile launcher upgrade for samus's
power suit upon activating its attack it
can be deduced that the choso meant for
this construct to protect their weapon
technology from those who do not fire
power beams those who are not the chosen
one that wears their power suit Samus
Aaron now Samus did begin this game with
all of her upgraded equipment including
the missile launcher and only lost it
all after an explosion on the space
pirate frig orphon knocked her suit into
a malfunction after which she landed on
Talon 4 so my thought process that
you're more than welcome to disagree
with is that choso prophecies must have
not only told them that their chosen one
would eventually visit the planet which
we know their prophecies did state but
also that she would need their help
hence why they had to create other
copies of her suits upgrades and scatter
them across the planet hence the missile
launcher that was placed under the hive
Mecca's defense the second chos a boss
in the game is the incinerator drone
which even shares the same Battle Theme
as the hive Mecca boss proving the choso
connection the purpose of why the
incinerator drone was built however is a
bit easier to understand than the hive
Mecca scanning the boss gives us the
information blatantly that it was a
choso machine created to dispose of
waste by incineration which is you know
probably totally healthy for the
environment they also gave it the
ability to defend itself if necessary
however so this leads me to believe that
the choso always meant for it to be able
to kind of sort of serve as a you know
death by fire machine in the case that
they needed to cause some enemies to
experience you know death by fire there
are also wasps called Barbed War wasps
that live above this machine although
they don't literally live inside it like
they did with the hi mecca it is unknown
why the Drone attacks Samus but because
of all the similarities to The Hive
Mecca both in design and location I can
only assume that this may have also been
the design of the choso a construct that
serves to protect the morphball bombs
that Samus needs from anyone who isn't
Samus it is of course entirely possible
that both of these bosses are simply
malfunctioning choso robots with
completely unknown purposes and that the
upgrades they just so happen to drop for
the parachute are not to be considered
canonical but I digress moving on let's
tackle the next and much larger group of
bosses those created by the dreaded
space pirates which in case you didn't
know are the intergalactic group of
alien beings that serve as the Central
antagonistic forces across the entire
Metroid franchise in fact they're
actually the ones responsible for the
outbreak of metroids across the entire
franchise including the planet Talon 4
notable members include the mother brain
and her high ranking leaders CRA and
Ridley the former of which is a huge
dude and the latter of which is the
swore Nemesis of Samus Aaron and don't
worry I'll be covering all of these
bosses in due time but back to the
bosses of Metroid Prime in the Prime
series of games the space pirates have
discovered fison due to its presence on
Talon 4 and have decided to try to
research the substance in order to make
bioweapons out of it for the purposes of
space Conquest which is the exact same
thing they tried to do with the metroids
the very first boss in the game the
parasite Queen is a direct result of
their experiments with the planetary
poison the space pirates selected a
durable parasitic species of parasitic
fauna from Talon 4 known as parasites
for genetic modification via phason
experimentation and thus created at
least three of the heavily mutated and
downright horrifying parasite Queen
variant aboard the orphon one of which
has freed itself and encounters Samus
directly in the ship's reactor room
which results in it fighting against
Samus and getting knocked down into said
reactor upon Samus shooting it enough
and causing the ship itself to blow up
both of the other parasite queens were
killed by space parrots themselves
before the ship self-destructed as
samus's log book entry States the
existence of the Genetically Enhanced
parasite Queen proves that the space
pirates had achieved considerable
results with their phason
experimentation and boy was it right
about that because they did not stop
with the parasite Queens this this led
the space pirates to begin to think
outside the box in new ways to apply
Fason experimentation because of this
they decided to create individual
projects Each of which would focus on
applying fison in different ways this
leads us to the next boss we'll be
talking about the sensient rock monster
known as tharis and you heard me
correctly this monster is literally a
combination of sensient rocks rocks made
sensient through the phason radiation of
inanimate objects in this case rocks
which became known as FAS on ore this
project was known as project Titan it's
unclear as to whether or not space
pirates specifically wanted to create
weapons from inanimate objects through
project Titan but given their track
record of wanting to make weapons out of
pretty much everything and some scans
from the pirate base in fana it's
heavily implied that this was in fact
the case however even though they were
successful in creating a living monster
that could control and weaponize the
elements in powerful ways out of
otherwise non-living material through
the use of phason radiation they were
not successful in maintaining any bit of
control over their newly created rock
guy who apparently just kept getting
more and more violent so naturally the
space pirates quarantined the poor Stone
dude in a cave and just kind of left him
there abandoning project Titan he drops
the spider ball upgrade for the morph
ball when defeated but even though
project Titan was abandoned that doesn't
mean the space pirates didn't have other
projects cooking behind the scenes which
leads us to the next project and
subsequently the next set of bosses
starting with the elite pirates born
from the marginally more successful
project Helix project Helix instead
focused on infusing fison not only into
living organisms butt into space pirate
DNA directly in fact they actually
decided to infuse space pirate embryos
with the substance but similarly to
project Titan's drawbacks their
experiments with growing Fason space
pirates led to the few surviving
subjects experiencing a severe mental
degradation that they termed Fason
Madness resulting in extreme bouts of
aggression killing any life form
unfortunate enough to come into contact
with them kind of like rabies eventually
however the space pirate research team
named team SL discovered a breakthrough
strain of fison codenamed vertigo phison
through their experiments with parasites
you know that parasite Queen business
this new vertigo fison was then used to
create the much more sane Elite Pirates
which were successfully matured and
trained for combat now as if that wasn't
already bad enough project Helix went on
to successfully fuse a space pirate
embryo directly with energized fison
instead of vertigo phison the result was
the much more powerful fison Elite which
attacks Samus with a different set of
abilities But ultimately serves the same
purpose as far as the lore of the
franchise is concerned the final Unholy
creation of project Helix would be one
Elite in particular known as the elite
pirate Upsilon or the Omega pirate this
individual was also fused directly with
energized fison just like the fison
elite but his abnormally high tolerance
for absorbing fison led the researchers
of Team Scalera to essentially juice him
with the stuff beyond all safety
measures the Omega pirate therefore is
significantly more powerful than any
other Elite pirate and possesses even
more Elite Powers such as the ability to
regenerate and cloak he also laughs in
battle which is kind of creepy upon
defeating the large dude he dies Falls
flat on top of Samus dissolves into pure
fison cooks and infuses into samus's
power suit creating the extremely
powerful fison suit which enables Samus
to absorb fison as energy and prevents
fison radiation damage entirely now with
both phason projects aside the space
pirates were responsible for one more
boss in the game although it is a very
quick and very easy to explain one and
admittedly kind of forgettable the
cloaked Drone is just that a flying
Sentry drone created by space pirates
with the ability to cloak itself from
the naked eye more importantly the room
in which it is located is within the
space pirate created phas on mins and is
called the central Dynamo now a Dynamo
is just another word for an electrical
generator and if s scans a computer
screen within the Dynamo we can read
that the Dynamo itself is powering the
phase on processing and security systems
interestingly another computer screen
tells us that due to bouts of phason
Madness in its workers the Dynamo has
been completely abandoned so in my
opinion this is why the croaked drone so
in my opinion this is why the cloaked
Drone was created it's simply a machine
built to safeguard the source of power
in the phas on mines instead of living
space pirate workers and alert nearby
Elite Pirates of any Intruders with the
bosses created by space pirates all
explained away let's now Focus solely on
the most infamous recurring flying
dinosaur-like space pirate in the entire
series Ridley or in this case meta
Ridley you have to specify you know I
mean the guy has several different forms
across nearly every Metroid game now I
want to State quickly that because his
appearance in this game is specifically
as the cyborg known as meta Ridley and
not as his normal Ridley self from the
first Metroid game and in order to avoid
going over the same material multiple
times across different videos I will be
ranking his full explanation deep diving
into his Origins placement within the
space pirate ranking and status as the
Archen enemy of Samus herself for my
Metroid zero Mission boss lore video
which was his first appearance
canonically after all so please stay
tuned for that and subscribe this of
course significantly cuts down the
information necessary to understand his
appearance as met ridly in Metroid Prime
following his death at the hands of
Samus Aaron in the first Metroid
Adventure on the planet zebes which is
the planet where Samus grew up and
apparently the planet where Ridley's
from although that's not really
canonical information his exploded
remains were apparently discovered by
fellow space pirates and because he was
such a good little murderous super
soldier they decided to not only
Resurrect The exploded space Dragon but
also upgrade him using their famed space
pirate technology giving him visible
metal plating for skin and many new
offensive abilities and wouldn't you
know it the location where Ridley gets
reborn as a cyborg is none other than
the space pirate frigate orphon you know
the one that Samus landed on at the very
beginning of the game and encountered
and killed the parasite Queen which blew
up the entire facility Ridley now
effectively meta Ridley Broke Free of
his medical restraints and escaped the
frig just before its destruction right
in front of samus's eyes clearly he made
his way down to the planet below for
unknown reasons because the next time
Samus encounters him is when he attempts
to kill her upon Sam's collecting all 12
choso artifacts and attempting to enter
the impact crater but more on that in a
second unfortunately for the big lizard
he just can't seem to get a win against
the girl in the power suit and thus
samis defeats meterle but just before
she can deliver a final decisive blow
against her foe the choso statues along
the tops of the artifact Temple seeming
come to life and shoot at him pushing
him off the edge of the platform and
into the impact crater below but don't
worry he doesn't actually die here no
Ridley keeps returning to life all the
way until Metroid Fusion and who knows
he may still come back to life in the
next game if the next game ever gets
made that is finally it's time to talk
about the last boss in the game and the
entity that the entire Metroid Prime
series is named after the Metroid Prime
itself now you might think that with a
name like Metroid Prime that means it's
the first Metroid but no this is
actually not the case the word Prime
used here just means that of all the
metroids encountered in the franchise
this would be probably the most
important or I guess another way to say
that would be the most individually
impactful there is a lot to cover both
canonical and theoretical regarding the
Metroid Prime so let's start first with
what we know about it from the game
remember when I was talking about all
that jargon regarding fison and its
origin Planet Faz and the Leviathan
meteorites being sent out of FaZe in
order to crash into and corrupt other
planets with their phon cores across the
galaxies well the one that hit Talon 4
50 years before the events of the game
created the giant impact crater within
which rests the Metroid Prime see this
is a little bit of a spoiler alert for
the video covering Metro Prime 3 since
this information is taken from that game
but according to findings in said game
when a leviathan from phase crashes into
a planet its source of fison the fison
core begins to seep into the planet and
as it does so the sensient phas on core
begins to attract the biggest and
baddest local Predator it can call out
to this Predator whatever species it
might be is drawn to the phas on core
and corrupted by it and reprogrammed
into being a powerful defender of the
phas on core in the case of Talon 4 and
its Leviathan The Predator that was
attracted to this core was none other
than a Metroid which is really really
unfortunate for the rest of the living
beings across the Galaxy as a reminder
pure metroids are practically Invincible
predatory life sucking organisms created
by the choso with the initial purpose of
feeding on and culling the much more
deadly and also Invincible parasite
known as X but I'll be explaining that
in the Metroid Fusion video they also
feed on
humans ow for now just know that
metroids are really really really deadly
and thanks to the space pirates finding
them and you know trying to make weapons
out of them like they do one thing led
to another and they ended up taking
metroids with them off of their home
planet of sr388 and across the Galaxy to
other planets such as zebes or in this
case Talon 4 space pirates doing
research things on metroids on Talon 4
led to some escaping and adapting to the
new planet and becoming known as Talon
metroids one of which was drawn to the
phason core after the leviathan's impact
and thus began feasting on and absorbing
the unlimited energy of the pure fyson
core causing a mutation unlike any other
Metroid in existence as it fused
directly with the fison core itself both
entities becoming one becoming the
source of all fison on the planet and
turning into the extremely dangerous
Metroid Prime now before I talk about
what happens with the Metroid Prime
after its encounter with everyone's
favorite blonde Bounty Hunter I'm going
to pause and Rewind a little bit the
more astute Metroid lore fans out there
watching probably know where I'm going
with this already but basically the fact
that a choso created Metroid that was
transported by space pirates found its
way to the fison core on Talon 4 is in
and of itself an enigma that has never
explicitly been explained to this day
but luckily or unluckily for you I
happen to love theories so here's what
makes sense to me see once the Leviathan
impacted Talon 4 it didn't take long for
faas on to spread through the planet and
thus for the choso to be alerted by this
in fact an ancient choso prophecy
actually foretold the coming of
something they called the worm which was
said to be born from parasites nurtured
in a poisoned womb devouring the world
from within which should sound familiar
and even though they didn't know it
would be a Metroid that would become the
foretold worm they did accurately figure
out that the Leviathan and its phas on
core are this poisoned womb that their
prophecies warned them of and because of
this and also because they were able to
see the corrupting effect of fison
before their very eyes they decided to
seal away the impact crater by building
the artifact Temple on top of it
otherwise known as the Cradle in hopes
to lock the phison Away by encasing the
entire impact crater in a
non-permissible energy Shield of course
we know that all this really served to
accomplish is to slow the spread of
fison down just a bit since its presence
still led to massive energy readings
being scanned from the planet which
attracted the space pirates and led to
their many phason mining operations the
energy Shield over the impact crater was
successful in barring the space pirates
from entry though which is a good thing
since they would have released the
Metroid Prime slumbering inside and
speaking of the Metroid Prime I'm sure
you're wondering what all this
explaining has to do with it well it
just so happens that metroids were not
present on telon 4 before being brought
there by space pirates like I mentioned
earlier and the space pirates didn't
arrive until they read the energy
readings of fison from the planet which
meant that the fison core was already on
the planet before they arrived which
means that the Cradle was probably
already created by the time they landed
a Metroid escaping captivity from the
space pirates and venturing off into the
Wilds of Talon 4 is believable enough
but the real question is how did this
Metroid Venture into the impact crater
and reach the phase on core if it was
already completely sealed off by the
Cradle energy Shield well allow me to
once again reach into the lore of
Metroid Prime 3 to theoretically answer
this question in Prime 3 Samus
encounters a new Evolution of metroids
known as Fason metroids which is exactly
that metroids infused with fison and
remember how I mentioned that fison life
forms such as the leviathans are able to
jump through wormholes in space well
phason metroids just so happen to
inherit this ability and they're able to
phase through local time space it's not
difficult to believe at all in that case
that a Talon Metroid brought by space
pirates to Talon 4 was either infused
purposefully with fison or exposed
itself to fison after escaping the
Pirates they do have several
Laboratories and settlements deep inside
the fison caves after all and they
already documented how some metroids
escaped captivity and once this Metroid
had evolved either by accident or by
design into a fison Metroid I think the
Leviathan began to draw the Metroid into
its core leading to the Unholy Fusion of
pure fison and Metroid the creation of
the Metroid Prime but this is just a
theory since it hasn't been proven in
game another possibility is that somehow
metroids also originated from phase
itself and therefore one of them was
already inside the Talon Force Leviathan
but that's also not a clean theory for
several other reasons but anyway
theories aside once Samus encounters the
Beast by unlocking the Cradle energy
Shield which was by the choses designs
since they also foretold the coming of
the entrusted one AKA samis she's able
to defeat it by destroying its body with
all sorts of beam fire and then
attacking its cord directly with pure
blasts of Fason until it is again
defeated and begins to completely
destabilize but very very importantly
just before it dissipates and dies for
good in one last attempt to live it
decides to grab a hold of Samus herself
and attempt to pull her inside
presumably so it can feed off of her
life force and prevent itself from dying
by using her as a new body she's able to
escape but only because the Metroid
Prime literally sucks the fison out of
her suit and absorbs it entirely after
Samus leaves it's revealed that this is
all that was necessary to create a new
body for the Metroid Prime one crafted
out of the phason infused DNA of Samus
Aaron and thus the Metroid Prime
undergos one final evolution into Dark
Samus herself along with inheriting a
power suit Dark Samus also inherits
samus's human intelligence becoming much
deadlier than the Metroid Prime could
ever have have hoped to be but that is
where this list comes to an end because
in case you didn't know Metroid Prime is
a Trilogy well technically there's a
fourth game but we'll get to that later
so make sure you're subscribed to stick
around for the boss lore of Metro Prime
2 when dark samus's Journey will
continue and please consider leaving a
like if you enjoyed this video or at
least my efforts into making it huge
thanks to everyone for watching and to
my Bandit crew for sticking with me
through the dry months and continuing to
support the channel seriously without
your support Bandit games would be a
thing of the past and thank you to
anyone who decides to support after
watching my videos let me know in the
comments below if there was anything I
missed or if you have a different theory
for the Metroid Prime and let me know
what other franchises you'd like to see
explored on the channel as well that's
all I've got for this one so follow me
on my socials and I'll see you next time
this is Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace
the